so I would like to follow up on how he
introduced me so introducing myself so
who is really at their most of the
people here don't know about me and if
you google Stanford University you can
have my bio but to make it short so I'm
specialised in brand and marketing and
I'm specializing media technology and
also globalization and corporate
governance and to give you my shortcut
of Korea I started my job as Richard
mentioned in a big company called
Mitsubishi Corporation so I was mostly
doing business in Japan and I didn't
have so much global experience on
business and I was involved in Lawson
which is the second largest convenience
store I was doing music download service
in the biggest record company called
Avox I was trying to sell a lot of
animation from Japan like Pokemon
hostage abuti which is like a Disney in
Japan but mainly my job was inside Japan
and then I had chance to count to us by
going to business school and then that
really transferred my career and then
after that I took the opportunity to
work in Hello Kitty company which is
Sanrio and then I had an amazing
experience over there and together with
that I also had an opportunity to work
at DNA which is one of the largest
gaming mobile company in Japan as an
independent director over there so I
started to learn and execute my
corporate governance career as well too
so I was really fortunate not just
because I had a business opportunity to
do but I had a lot of experience with
celebrities like you know him by doing
his the Rizla I had with Russell Simmons
web by gene Simmons with Paris Hilton
like Jeremy Scott who's a designer for
Nike and Adidas
Oh God he'll give himself or herself a
Japanese model Katy Perry I come and I
do Jeanne Moos himsel at her house like
a sister Paris Hilton like Neagle and
Janelle who is the designer for
undercover like bowling he's the movie
producer in Hollywood like so so many
Yoshiki yes a famous DJ mr. Tanaka
infra-red Pharrell is I think I you can
refer as the best music producer and
also I have experienced to have a
business relationship with today's
guests
it's a girl and she's one of the 70 in
Japan she does a lot of she owns her
company and she does independent
Bordeaux direct form a listed company in
Japan as well - so what did I do in Sun
real so this is the financial result
so why entered right after 2008 and
after that as you can see the cells and
also Aveda and also net profit are ovo
increased we had kegels 30% increase in
business for this five years and how did
I did that
so it was change about the mindset so
Hello Kitty was really something I knew
that it can go global but the company
was a very small Japanese company I
needed to take that mindset to
globalization and also I did a lot of
changing strategies which is for growth
in sustainability we were usually doing
business by retail ourselves sitting out
products but we change it to partnership
licensing mainly in the abroad and then
we also localized many things not just
the operation but design management and
the team as well - and also call we
already knew that there was a market in
the US Europe there was a market to
capture which we haven't really tapped
into and also we needed high discipline
we needed to grow this kind of - was
very important
and of course we needed to start new
initiatives such as how are we going to
manage the digital world such as
technology media but also going into
movie something like next Netflix s War
two so um as Richard mention as well too
I think many people yes believes that
entrepreneurship is startups you need to
start with your own thing but I think
there for me of course there was a
chance to start a new company as well
too but the journey I had was unreal and
the turnaround situation as well - for
me it was an entrepreneurship and I
wanted to elaborate on that after I left
Sun wheel in Hello Kitty business how
can I really utilize what I have
experienced so that's what I'm doing now
so I have my own consulting firm and
also I'm a visiting scholar and the
Richard as water but I'm also on the
board as an independent director
non-executive online which did the
biggest IPO last year as a tech company
in pigeon pigeon is a baby bottling
company they have almost 80 percent
share in Japan but also 40 percent in
China 60 percent in Korea it's one of
the biggest baby bottling company in the
global level in trans cosmos is the
biggest call center and back-office
function outsourcing company in Japan
and also social ventures which are
Richard also touched upon 250 million
venture capital here in Silicon Valley
so that's what I'm doing from last
summer so I would like to start up
today's conversation with Japan so many
of you know Japan but some of you might
not so Japan yeah so why Japan is a
little bit different from the other part
of the world so Japan as you can see
it's an island so it's separated from
other countries and then you might
remind Susi
like ramen and also like Kobe beef so
food everybody knows about it but
there's also other aspect of Japan as
well too like Pokemon like in Super
Mario and also Hello Kitty which I have
been devoting a couple of years in my
life but I think to go back to economy
so it has a population 126 million so
it's one of the biggest tense biggest
largest in population but also it has DB
GDP of five point five point four
trillion in PPP or nominal it's four
point eight so it's a big economy still
yes then many people have I think
positive and negative image of Japan so
some of the polls receivers i reinforce
that is still one of the largest market
in Japan and there's a lot of taking
people there is millennium generation in
Japan as well too there are a lot of
other adopters are they like details
they are well serviced and also it's
going to be a complement for many US
companies as a market or as a service or
as a business as well to meanwhile I
understand that there's a lot of
argument about Japan is low in growth
and also they missed a lot of
opportunities for example yeah we Japan
some people argue that they could have
been a bit yeah the second largest of
one of the biggest largest market but
it's falling down Chinese green and also
if you think about manufacturing yet
Japanese to be a very detailed and take
a company a country itself but many
people argue that even if Taiwan or
Korea right now and also yeah many
people in Japan is conservative that is
true and as I'm already touched upon
this a lot of competition is Asia many
people see Japan as one country but why
don't they think about China Korea
Taiwan but
I truly believe that there's a lot of
interesting points are in Japan and I
would like to touch upon a couple other
things which is really special in Japan
so for example people don't change just
amazing maybe they don't so this is a
chart of hiring and turnover it so you
can this is for the data I pulled out
from last year and as you can see
especially in 30s and 40s
only 7% or 8% people change this job
that means that probably like math one
out of 12 is a person who is going to
move over but here in the US if you are
in the thirties maybe you have like
change two jobs three jobs or maybe more
so this is a very interesting indication
because people try to find talent in
Japan when they go to Japan but they
want just because people just don't
change jobs especially when they grow
they tend not move and this is same for
females too there's a little bit of hi
ah ah hi the amount here but basically
it's the same people tend not to change
shop and also people still choose
conservative companies so if you see the
list
I saw the jump hunting list a couple
days ago um so your case I and the first
is where everybody wants to go to the
bank
Mitsubishi means a hall or airline
security company traveling insurance but
all of this is mostly basically well no
in big companies in the industry they're
going into basically bank or insurance
or air I so you can see how conservative
it is and also this chart hasn't changed
so much in just 10 20 years so this is a
very interesting list but this is that
the fact we have in Japan um and ah yes
when you look into going global course
a lot of elements I just listed not
going to go through every list but there
is of course a difference in style how
your work context the difference in
value or difference between not just I
think management but business model
that's a language HR but I think well
what I want to say here is however
people in the baton is looking for
innovation this this I think I see a lot
of changes especially in this couple
years even though you might think in the
surface it's really something
conservative nothing has changed so one
good example is pokemon gold the pokemon
is a company who has gaming in character
as well too but they partnership with
mop Niantic which is a startup here
which is a spin out of Google and you
already have seen how it has influenced
the world it's a new game it did
something very different from
traditional gaming and people loved it
so God I do see sign of changes and and
then yeah this is today's topic so
changing the boardroom and changes in
investment so I first like to start up
with our boardroom so god the board role
some people are familiar with board its
board of directors but I just want to go
over what the board is supposed to do so
first of all they need to have strategy
company needs to have strategy and the
most important things the board needs to
do is they need a strategy to increase
the value for all the stakeholders when
you say stakeholders sometimes of people
say about who owns the stock but it's
also about not just the stockholders but
I think usually there's still
stakeholders all over for example
consumers one the people you work is one
societies another so there's a lot of
things
you need to think about but I think it's
not for the sole interest of the CEO or
it's not the sole interest of the people
who working it's also volatile customers
so how do you really have a strategy to
align all those stakeholders that's one
of the important role of the board it
secondly reduce the risk because this is
a sustained me you need to have a
sustainable business you need to have a
sustainable companies of course there's
a lot of risk we can take but one of the
things you do at the board level is
minimize the risk people talk about of
course taking the risk but it's usually
the opposite how you redid we reduce the
risk to have the sustainability and then
you need to sometime make tough
decisions sometimes you cannot do by
yourself so people are with the team you
make tough decision here and also you
need to choose in fire the CEO that's
the people who are going to really lead
the company but you need to really have
that assessment and also you need a
succession plan in case you need to
change that CEO and lastly some people
say board is all the corporate
government things but the company needs
to innovate and that's one of the
important role of the board s or two you
need to innovate and how the typical
board member look like so I have two
example one is Walt Disney this is the
great one of the greatest company in the
US and I also have Toyota which is one
of the excellent company in Japan and
how Disney looks this for example this
is from their website so you have people
some of the pictures you are familiar
with so you have for example like Jack
Tosi from square and Twitter you have
people from Facebook you have people
from Nike you have people from Eli Lilly
you have people from Starbucks all those
CEOs and the only person
err who is the executive in this
Robert Iger so other than him basically
when you say the Board of Directors you
collect other people from other
companies so that this is how this D
board look like so how does Toyota both
look like so this so this is the board
of Toyota and I didn't look into all of
their resume you can click it and see
what they have been doing but most of
the people you see is I enter the
company in Toyota in the seventies and
then I have been working for years in
years and years and you don't see any
other people from outside the company
they might be one or two but I don't
know I I didn't check it off but this is
how he looks so I'd like to ask you so
uh what's the difference did you see
some difference so anyone yeah please
join me so yeah yeah
diversity yes very different diversity
what else you said Toyota there those
are all Toyota manager so it's very
similar very internal resources right
exactly
it's up only a single manager is on this
world right Toyota is very internal
meanwhile say a Disney is external yes
cultural memory and deep knowledge of
company in Toyota called culture and
acknowledges ah inside Toyota yeah
it looks like Toyota is and we're
looking Disney is looking outward
perhaps to expand markets or your
creative ideas yes
Toyota in word Disney looking out what
yes
Toyota has many members yeah definitely
yes you have many members because they
are afraid to make decisions afraid to
make decisions so they accumulate a lot
of people good point yeah anything else
yeah yes I think yeah those are the
great points you see so the differ
yes internal versus external so
definitely Toyota is internal ball army
while yes
Disney is looking external and other
people are external and there's
difference of executive in non-executive
as well so people in Toyota yes they
have deep knowledge about what they do
yeah because they being too beautiful
maybe 30 years old maybe 40 years yet
and the culture as well too
their executive meanwhile I think a
dizzy there's almost none of them other
than there are one person and also the
size definitely so how are you going to
make a decision with 40 50 people
meanwhile yes
hahaha you don't yes exactly
yeah that's what is happening and also
yeah composition and diversity you saw a
lot of diversity in Disney meanwhile so
Toyota you don't see any of it so this
is I think the change you can difference
you can see on the surface but more in
reality how do you conduct the board
meeting yes you're very very right so in
one sense I think Japanese people or
Japanese ball yeah usually don't make
decision and that that's I think one of
the things what it was both meetings
supposed to do versus management meeting
because usually in a meeting as such
there's a weekly meeting there's a
muskie meeting and everybody in
everything is the same as the board
meeting so he the discussion on
different kind of meeting with the
people yeah under US able to and then
basically yes the board means more isn't
something for reporting or not checking
something but it's usually not for
discussion some of the wall I have
observed for big companies in NZ five
minutes they don't have discussion so
that's a good great point and also I
think point of view
sharing information when I join couple
of other new companies on the ball I
asked a lot of questions so how are we
going to decide about no no I already
decided about it we did the monthly
meeting we did the weekly meeting and we
discussed it about for three months and
you're asking me questions why are you
asking that right now but there how can
you really fulfill the role of the board
meeting so I think it's very very
difficult in that kind of organization
or the size and also composition of the
board to share the information already
make up different point of view and also
I think it's about the process as well
so as I'm already touched upon on the
discussion they decision-making process
usually in the US or a lot of corporate
companies who have corporate governance
they put it in the board not outside of
the board or before the board so those
are the things that you still see
difference even though I see a tiny
changes so the board experience I had
some real DNA insurance cosmos vision in
line
some of the companies are new for
example DNA is only 10 years plus line
it's listed last year but it was founded
on 2011 top so not so long meanwhile
some real trans cosmos vision are almost
60 years old companies so there's a lot
of very different dynamics are among the
board and in the new board usually for
example the Union line we only have five
people six people we do discussion and
also I've changed a lot
so as I mentioned initially I was asking
to the board of non line and DMA so I
have questions but as I mentioned they
said no no this is already decided but I
reverse all the process that I can be
evolving that usually they ask me to
attend weekly mostly
eating but that was ridiculous I stopped
it at bar two months but I did try that
but that was too hard but instead I'd be
burst that decision-making process will
sit on the board and also some real
picture in trance cosmos sometimes is
very very difficult to speak out because
you saw the board meeting I mean board
member - Yoda there's a lot of people
whose be in the company for 30 years
you're starting coming in the room so
imagine so this is exactly the number of
the board member I come in and say to
you that you guys are wrong yeah exactly
and you the next thing you say that I
don't need share so please go out so
yeah to make an effective board it's
very very difficult in reality how to
enforce that and but yes it's really
hard to be held one person but that's
what I have been doing and interestingly
yes there's of course difference between
discussion and reporting people focus on
reporting but yes definitely there's
going to be a change when you try out
some I try to speak one the next time -
and then for example last boarding board
meeting I had with pigeon I was speaking
an hour it was supposed to end in an
hour but I had two hours so our people
start except why do they have accepted
because it's the kind of regulation it's
not it might be another willingness so
Japan changed the regulation that listed
company needs to have two people at
least two people are independent on the
board so go when I was born just alone
and it was really odd
but it once you have to person the
dynamics changes as well - especially on
the board you have 15 members or than
two people is enough to start to say
something and all those kind of thing is
going to be I think written in agenda so
you start to have an influence it might
be not a witness
from the company but Alisa those kind of
things are making Japanese company
really diversify yes
my experience with engineering of
management is that for the most part
they were interested but they always
turn to the ranking member
nor prove alike can we see that so how
would that be different at a board at a
board level yes that's a very
interesting question yes so basically
the ranking matters I'm not just in
ordering company but especially in
Japanese company engineering as well too
so they seek for higher ranking to have
an answer or have an agreement or have
an approval or what they do but I think
that's I think there's two things I did
for that so one is you define how what
is needed to talk on the board and of
that topic the board has the
decision-making so I have let some of
the company not make decision on
management level or weekly meeting so
this topic therefore needs to be
discussed on the board so you cut the
line so those topic come automatically
systematically comes in the board so I
can have a say or have a discussion and
the so called I think basically what I'm
saying is you can change the process so
as I mentioned yes as a custom yeah they
tend to ask the highest-ranking people
and get approval and everything is done
but that's not governance if you want to
buy a gas expedient company without a
sorry that hasn't happen but the
difficulties if it's convenient it might
happen but you need definitely need to
have I think a rule on the process what
needs to be discussed in in that scope
you will discuss on the board but you
really need an energy to change that
secondly I think it's mostly it's not
always about something positive
sometimes is a very negative thing like
problems or being issues with
manufacturing or issue with consumers so
um and one of the things I raised what
is needed in the bold level is the risk
management so those kind of things as
well - I implemented a lot of those
companies that system if there's
something wrong you need to report those
balls first not talk to your senior
manager and try to hide that and that
was what Kosovo was doing so I think
there's a certain way to manage that and
cooperate that on the board level and a
lot of things that have changed and I
never saw that I could change to be
honest with you I joined the board of
DMA and bid to be honest with you the
first board meeting they said I don't
want you to speak it really happened and
I didn't speak three months but uh
gradually I grabbed the trust and
studied the same thing and then started
the influent things and then somehow it
went well but I see a lot of file
changes and the people who saw that I
was affected in DNA started to say why
don't I join the board of other
companies so I was invited from many
companies line and also from trans
customers and also from pigeon from the
recommendation from the financial
investors I didn't go there and you know
I asked him to hire me but reputation
matters and also if you do something to
change that will lead you to another
change so I once again I never thought
that Japan would never change on those
governors I never thought that would be
one of the paper like Toyota's world me
but what that's happening and I'm like
this I'm very casual as I am today and
I'm still going to the ball where nobody
really like where rather than the suit
and why shirt so yes we're wired
that way and changing is it is it more
of a cultural kind of a thing or they're
legal or regulatory kinds of issues that
mandate they have these enormous boards
and all yes that's our three slides
before this I was mentioned yes it's a
regulation from 2015
Toshio regulated that you need to have
two independent board of director not
only nom so it's regulation yeah that's
pretty small right exactly by some might
think of with some countries for
diversity they say over 50% in some
countries say you need to have at least
one female some country said you need
diversification on color of your skin so
yes a diversification Japan is only
wanted to also others though what does
that change I totally understand but at
the same time yes
small changes well I think definitely
change the dynamics and I see that
really flowing into Japanese corporate
governance that's why I think yes this
sign of change of course I understand it
might be small change but it is a lot
influential change I ask are you saying
shareholders pushing words to do things
more than I'm sure other more activists
share over them yes so activist
shareholders yes it's increasing in
Japan something some activists say you
need to change the board you need to
have this independent board of directors
some people say no you need more
dividend because you have cash are in
your bag yes activist I think they used
to have making low attention in Japanese
market but since there's independent
directors well to those voices are tend
to admit directly going to the board
meeting and once those kind of
discussion comes for example to me I can
use that
as a voice of stockholders now one of
the stakeholders and then I push that
idea into the company as well - for me
that's one of the things I usually
utilize as a voice of outsider as well -
and change the corporate governance or
how the company's operating so I think
that's a great point as well - so yes so
for the time sake I will move into so
investment size of what I do
so this is solo benches so it has me
stub it's a fund established in 2011 so
it has six year history of it and it's
not a typical venture capital so what I
like it is it's a feature of the support
so it's a better capsule who enables
access to the market in Japan and also
we have businesses development teams so
basically we invest the company but also
we have helped to really penetrate the
Japanese market or make a partnership
and it's a win-win relationship with not
just as an investment but it creates a
revenue and also it creates a good
return for our the limited partners who
put money in nail fungus or - and this
is the kind of the portfolio we had we
have in the past so you can see Twitter
volunteer up our service Mac have been
bought square became listed as well - so
there's a plenty of company which is
called unique own type of company as -
and you see a lot of venture CEO saying
yes it was useful arm and so why do we
need Japan and what kind of option do
you have so once again when US company
it doesn't matter whether it's startup
or not usually they say I want to have a
100 percent
of city but as I mentioned people don't
move those so it's very very difficult
to hire people just because you can't
really have a great talent usually the
people you find in the market is B or C
type of people who are who has no future
in the company so they need to move or
they are old enough they almost retire
so they want to challenge the thing but
it's not in the surges or for this is
late 50s or 60s so do you want to have
them in the startup environment I don't
know so we usually recommend for more
partnership with joint venture
distribution agreement licensing
crossbow or if it's a digital solution
just to be close cross border you don't
need a subsidiary in Japan
oh yeah if you have a great products you
just do the marketing there oh I think
in localization let's localize with a
partnership and and to do this you need
to understand the market you need to
find the right partners and of course
that you need to do well you need to
have a team to do business development
in additionally you need a fireman so
that's how where we sit so we finance we
help them build the team with the
partners and then I find opportunity are
in Japan in and image as well too so I
can say that it's a new type of BC
because more than half of all team use
basically my business development so we
have a capacity to increase business and
also it's a new vision with passion we
want us technology company to conquer
Japan in Asia ah
and the soca we created new trend after
we may solve oh ah there's a lot of fun
following up on arm to do these kind of
things but business development is not
that easy so well we still have a lot of
advantage on our sources model but it's
a new type but the other way to say that
to begin with
Japanese companies are looking outside
for innovation this is I think most
important but sometimes people are
missing because we're talking about BC
and we're talking about startup but the
wider Japanese companies to begin with
once the partnership will start up in
the US or gozman companies are all over
the world it's because they're looking
for innovation assume as you have seen
yes
Toyota has a big organization with a
very conservative board but they need to
innovate and they're looking for a lot
of partnership outside of the country
outside of the company they can't carry
that inside so that's why they want
partnership and that's why so they can
bridge that so I think those are the
changes you see I think there was less
eagerness to partnership in Japan maybe
10 years ago but we are serious about it
many Japanese companies are serious
about it we raised 250 million over 250
million
as I've mentioned all of them are owned
Japanese company they want to innovate
that's why they put money in a funk ah
so signs of the changes here too so I
have like 3040 minutes left here so I
just I wanted to open up for questions
and discussion to the class
[Applause]
pores open so it's just understanding
that exchanges you stare at you go they
are you look around you change think
personally whether it is your
prostitutes will to you Candice panel to
try to activate dynamics operating you
stop what is the method this leverage to
push on okay
track me and we go yes
so God so what am I really changing in
reality maybe I'm not haha there that's
a good great question so and how am i
exactly doing that yes and with a couple
example ah for example call so come yes
it's videotape so I I don't want to
touch upon something which is under NDA
guy my view also something
aha yeah no no I'm just saying that it
might be ambiguous but yeah I'm very
sorry that it might not translate well
but I just wanted to say that maybe it's
not clear just because I'm trying to
avoid something yeah yes but for example
uh when people are looking for
acquisition for example so let's have a
target and then everybody is looking
inside Japanese company and but I I work
here I live here so why don't we have a
candidate here to look into the market
as well to this is a very simple but
very different dynamic
just because you seen the board of
Toyota yes of course the Toyota has a
broad range of people who work in a
broad as water but many companies they
don't so you for example I was in the
board of Sanrio and there was fifteen
people
nobody represented abroad only me so
everybody wanted to do business inside
Japan and their executive on those
divisions so you have like the executive
slim Park you have exactly four v-tail
you have executive from by sensing but
all in Japan so they want to put their
resources to abroad so that was my
initial situation and it's very
difficult to change the dynamics because
everybody wants to focus on Japan why do
we into acquisition in the u.s. they say
no no no we don't want to put that but
at least those conversations are start
to think about what are we going to do
on abroad and I think yes it's sub-2 but
a Lisa it gives a certain idea that we
need to talk about abroad and in a year
or two years the dynamic really changes
just because I change the business as
well to the profit the sales more than
fifty percent is now from overseas we
were talking about it two years three
years ago you said it was definitely a
bad idea
the our situation change we are ready so
why do we work on it
so I think many changes you can do it
one day but I think you know what I'm
trying to do what I've been trying to
have is a I think I'm to certain extent
take a long time but in two years and
three years it's going to be different
dynamically put some small ideas for
three and then when it grows out you
push it
yes so I feel my followers kind of the
question through in the time that you
and I've worked together while you've
been a visiting scholar here you've
brought me various kinds of ideas for
business development for some of the
companies that you're on the board off
and so I'm really curious if you see
that bringing in new business gives you
more clout on the board is that one of
your reasons for doing this or what
just sort of that's a responsibility of
everybody on the board hey um um yes
they know
I sit on the board of three companies
but I advise 15 companies which are is
not official so I cannot say which
company and on the board
once again the
all my role my role is to I think have
the right strategy and also have the
sustainability so assess the risk and
you need to think about the team CEO and
all that alignment are within the
company so the most of the usual work
you do is not something fancy which I
enjoyable too but at the same time when
you advise or mentor the new startup CEO
you're talking about I think something
very different so you don't need to
think about the risk now you should take
the risk I can say it loudly because I'm
representing myself or my opinion
meanwhile when you're in the board you
can't just say what you think or you
cannot represent just your expert yes I
am professional on IP but that's not the
role I need to think about the MA they
call exactly right so it's really
different how I act okay thank you
you convert a lot of questions to that
so you mentioned that you're on the
board of three companies you've been on
a board of other companies but you have
these 15 companies that you advise so
why why did you make a decision to take
those three what was your thinking
process when you were assigned or you
were invited to many companies
yes so go why did I choose three
companies and why yes and why am I still
getting to advise company so um and by
the way I'm repeating for the video so
for the mic and so yes that's a very
interesting thing I always had the dream
regardless of leaving sunny or not they
got this area independent board of
director is going to be something
different in Japan so I was on the board
of DNA way before the regulation was
there and I thought it's going to be
something additional to my career just
because the increasing listed companies
from young startups they have experience
out on of course making a company but
they're still sergey's a forest I was
at the time I swore to and they needed
somebody to really assistant but the
only person who was on the list for
independent directors were lawyers
conference ah university professors who
are like oh I guess it I can't hit him
brother
I'm very sorry no I didn't have that
intention but of course there's a very
experienced university professors but
they are so who are not but I just
thought maybe my globalization my
experience I can utilize that as a new
wave in Japan so I was really looking
for that so I was i already declared I'm
going to do that Wow I think it was
around 2012 so I was really looking
forward with those kind of opportunity
and since I was raising my boys to have
that position I think many people
started to ask me as well too
so that was I think one of the goal I
wanted and I really believe that I can
really innovate change influence the
board of being one or two member of
independent board of director so that
was kind of the dream but at the same
time I wanted to have my expert which is
marketing or branding IP to utilize that
and also I see a lot of potential not
just allocated there's many cool Japan
items I want to bring into Japan from
Japan to the US so I'm helping those
kind of companies to go global which has
nothing to do with governance and
startup so you don't need some time
governance so nuts are kind of the
things I enjoy that's water
oh good you have a question yes I'm
interested in the decision-making
process with Japanese companies my
experience is that there is a huge
resistance to talk directly and openly
what about problems decisions I made
before before they are actually make
Frank you indicated that as well so do
you see a change and because this goes
very much to the world of the cultural
change
right and if I do see the change of
decision-making process
it is true that people don't like to
discuss in front of people and they try
to avoid the discussion every discussion
is a manga yeah in the other room that
are still true but at the same time
sometimes is so efficient just because
you need to talk of ten people in
different rooms and still I think it you
need both but at the same time when you
really have an issue or you really need
a consensus putting everybody in the
room and talk about it is still I think
the fastest and also effective solution
yes it's true that people don't like to
have that but at the same time I think
they get used to especially I tell
people that I'm going to raise this
topic I did that is unreal sports so
much yeah I love the whole hand that I'm
going to talk about it so they really
didn't like it yeah when I yeah and I
was addicted I was not independent but
they said no I don't want to talk about
it and I just submit a material I want
to discuss about it and they cannot
avoid it so I think the other way to say
if you have a courage to really wanting
to talk about it and the meaning is
officialized you need to talk about it
and I think it was very difficult to do
that when you didn't have independent
directors just because everyone is
internal and say why are you talking
about and everybody can hide about it
but if you have one to independent
director who has nothing to do with we
may hear something really weird or
something they believe they need to
discuss about it the dynamic change you
cannot avoid the discussion so I think
yeah the dynamics are is changing that
way so that kind of actually comes back
to what you had mentioned earlier about
there being this sort of hierarchy even
in a board they're sort of a hierarchy
based on seniority and the company and
here you are younger than most of the
people
in Toyota anyway and speaking up and
that kind of thing how I think just do
it I know I think this is I think
fundamentally what independent director
needs to think about now they should
attend the independency of who you are
what you are also of course I'm taking
the risk I'm taking the responsibility
but I'm okay um being fired any time if
they have all projections okay and also
if they don't have an ear condition I
will probably leave myself that's my
attitude don't wanna do is there is a
you said Roylott Japanese companies
usually in outside innovation so I've
experienced obviously Japanese companies
and it's been successful sometimes and
not successful all the times kind of
depends but now I'm visualizing myself
coming into the board okay and I want to
I want to move on where they're going to
see something different than I'm going
to say well let's talk about destructive
industries of concepts and strategies
destructive like uber how is that going
to play out nope ah they gonna
I think while this is up this is way
over the top but in fact they could be
at risk for being targets and that may
be very useful to them when when that is
going to happen and I'm curious to know
I'm not using it is a danger in say oh
well am I going to really try this or am
I going to get kicked out disruptive
innovation yeah right yes I think it's
there's two thing I need to say one yes
of course to begin with people
internally doesn't think their business
is going to go away so they don't even
think about something disruptive
so those topic doesn't come in mind at
all
so me but they don't think about it so
there's maybe a discussion or an idea
about it so you never talk about it yeah
and and secondly I think yes I even with
independent board of directors sometimes
yes those topic are sensitive in
difficult but at the same time I think
if but I think on the agenda of the
board usually I think you should have
some topic such as what is going to
destroy our business what is going to be
destructive service or product those are
the agenda usually you follow up eerie
if you are on the board of I think US
company or our other countries so think
of one of the things I'd change is so
what are the ten biggest risk we have
and one of it is for example
distributive service in fact I did talk
about the stock destructive products the
second board meeting of pigeon
so pigeon is a baby bottling company and
and for example if you see a futuristic
movies so people like babies they don't
have baby bottles they are born in a
kind of cubical water amazing so nobody
have a baby below so what is going to be
so somebody in the company now baby
bottle everybody is going to have a baby
and it's come not going to be the
structure is going to continue forever
so we are safe that was one of the I
think I heard a message
oh wait a moment so in the 50s movie I
like I don't see any baby water anymore
so what are we going to do in the next
20 cities if those kind of error comes
and people were like oh oh my god what
is betraying true that so you know once
you start to say those kind of thinking
started touch upon them people are
startled look into technologies and we
did look into a lot of technology
company and we are doing new activities
so I'm going to move over here for two
questions you go first
okay you know what is the most benefit
for us setups to make a partnership with
Japanese countries compared to other
countries other Asian countries come -
yeah um I think yes there's a couple
tendencies I see this is not just Japan
but mostly Asia so - some people say
that they are a lot easier to influence
and that means something that's a bad
way of saying but the good way of saying
is is a whether the trend are people has
a very high speed on adopting
technologies so if you have reserved you
yeah in Japan like if you have a service
like line and then you started and then
you have the whole speed of penetration
it's not just I think the service but I
think it's kind of technology thing as
well - adoption mas you are convinced
the mass market is convinced is going to
go over the market is very fast and as
it mentions I think the market side is
still big you can generate the sales and
profit from the market quite easily ah
once you penetrate that of course or how
to penetrate how to enter that is
difficult but once you do that there's a
certain market and I think compliance do
you follow the agreement how are you
going to really take the risk on both
sides and also I think Japan is quite
consolidating in certain industries so
if you talk with one retailers and then
you have a certain big share so I think
there's a easy for easing yourself doing
businesses for - so of course it depends
on oh what industry you are but there is
a benefit for startups so for example we
partnership with a lot of at linka
startup company and when we introduce
our distribution easily they became one
of the world's largest sales channel so
those kind of thing really happens a
Stanford loss with Valley directors
exchange last November 2015 that average
for compensation from the Silicon Valley
150 biggest companies was nearly three
hundred thousand two hundred eighty nine
thousand per board number and that it's
for the chair it was four hundred fifty
thousand in terms of entrepreneurship in
the boardroom in Japan and from say the
startup from zero point zero to Silicon
Valley hundred sixty
how does board compensation work in an
entrepreneurship way I see yes so that's
a very interesting thing so board
compass called compensation for startups
in full district companies as well too
so most of the company I advised are in
Japan arm they want to pay cash and yeah
interesting yes
and most of the companies I advise in
Silicon Valley they want to give me
stock option yeah so when you think
about yeah of course that there's a
difference on amount but to start with
Japanese cell company they usually don't
have stock option also but anything you
have I think the culture of Silicon
Valley as well - you're not giving the
cash but you're sharing and then the
interest and also I think the upside of
what's going to happen in the future so
god the way I think of they compensated
Japan is very different and this is not
just a big about startup but it's same
with the big companies as well - I have
no stock oxygen program for any
companies listed companies I actually
asked for that and many people argue
that there's a conflict of interest by
independent directors shouldn't have
stock option oh yeah you love that
you love that was what I was said so I
think the mindset of cycling is very
very different from country to country
and especially I think the culture of
Silicon Valley and culture a diesel in
Japan right now it's different and also
since you are paying out forecast the
app mount sometime is smaller in Japan
ah because of course you don't have a up
side but the cash you have for start-up
it's not so much so many startups I
think the compensation for our
independent board of director it's 20 K
or 30 K that's what I hear and we've got
by the way without stock option so
that's I think one of the reason why
Japanese startup a week they don't have
stock option program they don't employ
advisor but for example yet now one of
the company advice here it's a big
startup they raise over 200 million
already and they ask me for advising
that company and interestingly they send
me a file yeah DocuSign yeah it signed
this and I receive a certain stock
option and in a week and then I grabbed
them a five million gear in one week so
that's what kind of things you can do as
an adviser but for some of the Japanese
company yet they say on the yeah sequel
advise I hear nothing for a year or two
and then I can't do nothing of course I
can I say something but I can't help
them and so I think um I want to really
employ those kind of system which is
very I think critical crucial and
beneficial for startup into Japanese
community as water I think those I think
very good custom and the way of doing
startups here right I'd like to ask the
follow-up question about Sozo ventures
so you're helping American startup
companies partner in Japan for Japan
market entry usually the Japan partner
is a big company
do you ever partner with Japanese
startup companies usually what we
recommend on social ventures is we
should partnership with a strong
Japanese company because the resources
you have for example if you think about
like a or B or C realm in the u.s. you
raise 5 million 10 million 20 million 30
million in sometimes 50 millions mean
why in Japan when you are talking about
injuring one in a and B and C it's
usually up to 2 3 million or maybe 5 but
not so much so the resources you're
talking about for start-up is very very
different and also if you are talking
about D and E rail and also an exit or
being listed in Japanese company
sometimes they got listed with 50
million variation 100 million then you
can go to listed market like mothers
those are the kind of the targets for
you have to exist so usually I think a
start-up in Japan they are very small
limited resources and also called if you
think about US companies to globalize as
well - you don't want to partnership
with someone who doesn't have enough
resource to support your activity in
Japan and many stars in Japan doesn't
have that resource so I usually don't
recommend our Japanese startup to be
their partners and also as I mentioned
in many area in Japan is consolidated
they are leading companies they have
shares and they don't have innovation
just because if you are in the board
room of the company they have been in
the company for 4050 years so there's a
lot of great chance to implement those
kind of technology to big companies
rather than small so a user recommend
big companies to partnership with
include 30 questions
oh I have a question about your thoughts
on serving as a member on the board of
directors it seems to me that the
Japanese new regulations with respect to
compliance or accounting or disclosures
the letter of the regulations and are
pretty similar between the two countries
so not so much from the regulatory or
compliance perspective but the
philosophy or the provision of mission
perspective Japanese companies seem to
always have you know comparing similar
companies smaller return on equity or ro
Yi or ROI compared to US company they
tend to look short to long term in terms
of their return so they'll keep a lot in
retained earnings for those future
investments whatever that might be our D
or facility expansion on the US side
though it seems to me that originally
the idea was to look out for the best
interest of the company including all
the stake holders like I said earlier
but the bottom line is how much money am
I going to get in my return this quarter
almost right through the quarterly
financial analysis that they go through
and the performance of that company is
often evaluated on a quarterly basis
often based on the money aspect and
Japan is maybe not so much if they look
at the business as a whole short
I'm sorry not so mid to long term so
with these very different types of
philosophies and you being on the board
of probably both how do you reconcile
those right yeah so I think your
question is us have more short-term
targets ah and opening and also focus on
more on returns meanwhile Japan has more
median long-term and sometime they
sacrifice the profit so how do you
although I mitigate or a band or
something I think um there's a well at
least I think I try to look into both
side in a good way so why Japanese
company look for mid and long term is
because as I mentioned people don't
change up so people are in the company
for 40 50 years and then when you become
CEO the likeliness is that you're going
to stay in the company for another two
years if it's a company like Kosovo
others you become CEO 65 and then you
have the room in the company until 85 or
maybe a hundred seriously so there's 20
of them it's not just one but that's the
kind of thing you have you have a
boardroom but you have completely
different boardroom you plug in the
exactly you have four decades in the
other room waiting for you and so people
have so basically what I'm trying to say
is their own interests it's not really
the company sometimes I feel so they try
to protect they try not to make mistake
they try to not get those people away
just because you know that you're going
to be that person very soon and you want
their for another 20 years and that is
the compensation they receive to see
every CEO in this company Japan it's
still so I think 200k 300k that's that's
the listed company CEOs compensation but
you are expected to receive that for
another 20 30 40 years so that's what
people can really hang on to the CEO job
just because they have another 20 years
so usually their successor is the P
person who is going to hire here for
another 20 years and will not betray you
so I think in reality yes yes I
initially thought that is really for the
company but is really
so sometimes that damages the company
and at the end it's just conservative so
I think yes of course sometimes people
do I may have mission objective or
middle long-term but many cases it's
really not so I disagree that that it's
really something yeah special but I
think there's good part on that as well
too because you don't sacrifice the
short-term Pro sort of them just to make
sort of money and at the same time I
think what's the beauty of the u.s. is
yeah of course you are looking for
shorter but it's really number driven
and sometimes I think this whole
qualitative and quantitative and in
Japan is more qualitative relationship
you know that and in the u.s. it's we
are more quantitative you look into
numbers ie you calculate ROI a ROI
re in Japan sometimes people don't know
about it even you're the CEO of the
company you just don't look into numbers
so I think there's a thinker both good
side and if you have both sides of the
management style I think it's always
better so I haven't I don't have the
right answer how to benefit but if you
learn both and try to implement the best
part of both side I think it's better
anyway
really how are Japanese companies big
firms doing at getting innovation from
outside are they starting to figure out
how to do this yeah I think so yeah at
least is 3 things you are seeing changes
so one is venture capital investment so
and by companies remove Apple so ok they
they have incorporated venture capital
many companies started to do that office
in Silicon Valley and also they are
limited partners for many venture
capital as well too so at least they
want to invest money into where the
innovation is secondly I think our R&D
centers what
so basically I'm not just investment but
they are trying to employ the new
engineering people not just Japanese but
outside as well and also there are
acquiring companies with has technology
of course many fails but Alisa you see a
lot of things are trying and also I
think of new companies buy a lot of new
startups in Japan as well so these are
our eco eco system in Japan as well to
how those startups are going to exist so
sometimes they of course are have a
market to be lifted but many companies
got bought out by big companies now okay
other questions
go ahead I'm very thank you for all the
very insightful two remarks I want to go
back to the topic is entrepreneurship on
the boardroom and there have been some
really interesting comments on corporate
governance and in particular this last
question about us in Japanese models I
think it's interesting that while the
statements you made about the role of
the board in many US boardrooms I think
that would have been an extremely
controversial statement to come out and
say that the role of the board is to
look out for all stakeholders and it's
about innovation and it's about
sustainability there are a lot of
business school professors and board
members who had found the table and
absolutely not our job is to be here to
maximize shareholder and that's actually
a change in the US over the last 30 or
40 years used to be much more consistent
with what you articulated maybe not as
much the innovation starts a long
direction but my question is for CEOs
who like the model you're proposing who
want to try to build that model in the
US and who are in an environment where
that actually is a controversial model
what advice do you have for a CEO as he
or she is putting together his or her
board of directors yes so yeah that's an
excellent question and also
controversial so guess since I'm my
background needs more
Simar product I might be more sensitive
to stakeholders for example if you want
to have Hello Kitty product in Walmart
you need to assure that those products
are not made by slaves child slaves and
if you have that your brand reputation
all goes away so of course I in the
short term are making those products
without knowing what factory it is it's
most cost effective you don't need to
look into it you don't want to look into
it maybe short term profit yes but but
time by time people find out and it's in
the media and you need to really cope
with that that's not just not us it's
about HTML it's a Disney as well to most
of the consumer products company of
course yeah we're talking about
shareholder return but at the same time
what is that at the end you need to
satisfy I think this social environment
as well too
or otherwise people will not buy a Hello
Kitty products or Disney products so and
in some industry you might not need it
you now might not need that sensitivity
but in especially in consumer products I
think we have been very sensitive about
it
so how for example Nestle has water
so where did that cockle came from if
you you need to be sure that that cackle
was not product from slavery child
slavery and if you buy from a market in
Africa
you cannot assure that so some cockle
company has been buying a lot of forest
folk a call themselves that they want to
make sure about it and also some people
are implemented digital technology to
make sure that this is a farm where
there's no such kind of things and I
think our sense of the world is getting
smaller I think when you talk about
shareholders and also
sometimes I think there's a direct
dynamic so which company and both
consumers had you really need to keep
attention on so God and that goes back
to diversity so if you are an industrial
prayer and you don't have direct
consumer relationship so you don't care
about no I'm going to make this whatever
it is but if you are in consumer
products there's a lot of things that we
already change it's a very different
clothes industry but you don't know so
that comes back to composition in
diversity so think to have that kind of
sensitivity I think it's very important
have a certain diversity education in
the board and you will have the
attention because you're from the
different kind of the world you need to
have that attention and I think it's not
just about consumer product I think I
can happen on all those elements or to
global is one so yeah let's
I only when you are talking about US
market and everybody's us the biggest
shareholder return is the big market in
the US but they might be a big market in
China so you're doing nothing in China
so and then if you have the diversity in
the wall you will think about your rule
start to think about China and also I
think there's a dynamic on changing for
example I had a chance to go to luxury
brands meeting last week in Shanghai and
they were talking about like jeans denim
so um so right now only 19 percent of
the people are we're engaging in China
so it's going to increase in 60 80
percent so what are we looking into I
also like a lot of brand as Walter used
to be in the 80s it was one percent
China nobody was like buying luxury
brands but it's now suggested two
percent so sometimes you have a notion
that no we don't need to do that but if
you have a diversified board or
diversify kind of information you start
to think about different kind of thing
and the landscape you see the picture
you see might be very different that's
why I think diversity is very important
and with that I think regardless of I
think the attention of the board I think
it's going to be widened and I truly
believe that if you have the diversity
you have more I think success or making
decision so I think the key to your
question is have a diversity diversity
have people who are not related to your
industry and then you will have
different kind of sensitivity healthcare
is very different industry if you are
doing mobile again it's very different
but if you have the sensitivity in the
board your things different thing car
automation as well - some people think
automation is very technologically but
companies like Toyota
it's about life so how you're going to
save it so you need to have the
sensitivity meanwhile many technology
company doesn't have that sensitivity
you need to have that diversity to think
about it that's an excellent point to
close the session today we've got some
refreshments outside let me recommend
that we go outside for the refreshments
but first please join me in thanking
Raisa
[Applause]
you